how's it going everyone my name is  Pierre as you can see I'm still in Italy  it's my last day here and I've been have  I've had the best five days six things  or whatever in a long long time I've  been here with my girlfriend I know a  lot of you wanted to see her but she  wants to be reserved and I can tell you  she is gorgeous so you should be happy  for me really  I'm sad that I have to leave but I'm I  don't know anyway and it's good too I  miss making videos still so that's one  thing at least I have forward going back  to I haven't examined the 26 I have to  write so I'm probably not gonna upload  videos instantly after I get back to  Sweden so you have to wait a little more  for me  [Music]  my real doom is making videos which is  pretty much by making this blog um we're  going out now for some dinner I'm  freaking starving and we always eat like  that's how and yeah that's pretty much  it